fortnight is currently one of the most
played game since it hopped on the
recent Battle Royale wave and while it's
available now and free to play on Xbox
one and ps4 the PC version is arguably
the best way to play this increasingly
popular survival shooter while we're
here to break down what kind of visual
quality and frame rates you should
expect with a quick graphics settings
guide with some performance tips this is
an epic games title for night uses
Unreal Engine 4 but when looking at the
minimum specs you'll see the game sets a
very low bar to clear especially by
today's standards at the bare minimum
Epic says you'll need an Intel Core i3
dual-core processor clocked at 2.4
gigahertz 4 gigabytes of RAM and intel
HD 4000 integrated graphics however it's
recommended that you have at least a
core i5 quad-core CPU at 2.8 gigahertz
eight gigabytes of RAM and a gtx 660 or
radeon HD 7870 video card of course
you'd want a little more juice than that
to get an ideal experience with this
game so as we did with our graphics
guide feature from player unknowns
battlegrounds we tested out what we
could get out of a modest older
mid-range system our test bench is
equipped with a core i5 35 70 K CPU at
3.4 gigahertz with 8 gigabytes of RAM
and a 4 gigabyte MSI GTX 970 now that
we've outlined our test bench let's peer
into the graphics settings fortnight
allows you to tinker with 4 PC gaming
veterans the graphics settings menu
shouldn't be surprising however with
fortnight's exploding popularity and
free-to-play model there's sure to be
some players wondering what some of
these terms mean and how it effects
their game resolution is the first thing
to address and we recommend using your
monitors native resolution throughout
this video we're using 1920 by 1080 also
known as 1080p we have the game set to
full screen with an uncapped framerate
3d resolution is essentially resolution
scale this allows you to effectively run
a lower in-game resolution without
having to force your computer to change
from its native res it's really only for
low-end systems so you'll definitely
want to keep this out a hundred percent
otherwise your game look nasty view
distance dictates the point at which
minor objects are rendered since this
game revolves around a large scale
battlefield it's best to keep this as
high as possible and here we're able to
run it at the
exciting but it doesn't impact
performance or visual quality that much
you're still able to see structures
buildings and enemies off in the
distance even at lower quality shadows
of determines the quality of object and
player shadows it can also be turned off
completely but we recommend at least
using medium because in a few instances
seeing a player shadow around the corner
or poking out behind cover will help you
track and anticipate enemy movement it
could help you get the jump on them
anti-aliasing gets rid of jaggies around
the edges of objects and surfaces to
higher the setting the smoother and
cleaner the overall image will look the
medium option uses fxaa which doesn't
look the best but hardly affects
framerate but here we have enough power
to spare so we use the high setting
which uses temporal anti-aliasing and
looks real nice textures affects the
detail on surfaces simple enough so long
as your graphics card has enough vram
our 4 gigabyte GTX 970 handles the high
setting without a problem if X is a
little bit tricky and that you won't see
a difference in visual quality and frame
rate until explosions and destruction
fill up the screen since these
situations are the most hectic and most
important to maintain a high frame rate
we're gonna go with a modest medium
setting here post-processing encompasses
effects like ambient occlusion and
dynamic lighting we kept it to medium
and saw some visual improvements but
it's one of the lesser noticeable
settings when it comes to graphical
quality and framerate motion blur comes
down to preference and vsync should
always be left off alright we have our
specs outline and graphics options
explained now we can get into some
performance numbers we're gonna give a
general range of frames per second
throughout the several matches we played
a fortnight battle royale our goal was
to find a balance between frame rate and
visual quality with the settings we
chose and we were able to maintain
between a hundred to 150 FPS as we
traverse the map and comb through the
streets of the more busy city centers
when things got heated in a firefight or
FPS range between 80 to 110 FPS overall
we never experienced the dip below the
gold standard of 60fps say you're on a
slightly lower spec machine we would
recommend turning down anti-aliasing a
notch or two and if you're still in need
of some more frames turning shadows down
will have the biggest impact
turning effects down to low can also
help stability during intense battles we
also tried running the game with
everything cranked up to epic and got an
FPS range of 50 to 85 this isn't bad by
any means so if you want a bit more flow
a mid-range system can handle it on the
flip side with all the eye candy turned
off we were able to get up to 250 FPS
with dips to about 170 FPS during action
this shows a lot of flexibility for
low-end systems to work with fortnight
it's just as we expected foreign aid is
hardly a graphically demanding game it's
no surprise given the art style that's
not to say the game doesn't look great
because there's certainly an appeal to
the more lively animated look a
fortnight however what we atleast know
is that the game runs smoothly with very
few if any technical hiccups despite its
large scale long story short it's
optimized well we hope you learned a
little something about graphics settings
or got some context as to how fortnight
battery outperforms on PC you can also
check out the full written feature on
GameSpot thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time
[Music]